let me show one tweet i want to get uh
seth's feedback here go to go to uh
our friend robert reich the motivational
speaker
um who said do you know how much ceo pay
has skyrocketed since
a hundred percent 500 percent try
this is unsustainable huh i responded
it's a source of inspiration for kids to
be a ceo one day mba is 1978 mvp bill
walton made a hundred thousand dollars
now steph curry makes 46 million dollars
a year that's an increase of 46 000
percent is that unfair that people
playing a game make more money than ceos
creating a job i'm happy for both you
sound bitter towards ceos fyi you know
how much the highest paid professor
makes in america today
do you know the number highest paid
including book sales or no no just
highest paid professor what do you think
he makes he or she makes it a 100 grand
man
way more
no more i'm actually curious what you
say they don't make a ton of money man
give me the highest paid professor how
much i make that i actually researched
this yesterday the high i gotta assume
it's somebody that teaching law at the
university at harvard or something like
that
i'm making a million dollars a year 400
grand okay that's a lot of money for
professors for the highest paid highest
value makes four hundred grand plus
yeah the professor
so highest paid professor in america
today i want to i want to pull this up
highest paid professor i don't know if i
send you to robin d'angelo 50 000. no no
no no you're about to be shell-shocked
the highest-paid professor in america
today pull it up it's the first one
right there go up there david silvers
folks he makes
ready
4.33 million a year what professor
clinical professor has dermatology and
pathology
4.3 million dollars zev rose and wax
makes 3.3 million dollars professor
these poor professors are broke yeah
what are they going to do are they
getting paid by the sheep school that
amount or they're they're making that in
their career and then they happen to be
able to take that as a professor two
points
keep going down these are private
universities at least that's okay
william 1.9 million 1.19 million anyways
so so the point is the point is
should we not pay these professors i
don't care if they're making that kind
of money totally fine with that yeah
yeah they never go after nba players for
the amount of money they're making hell
what's his name mahomes just got a half
a billion dollar contract and he bought
the royals as a 22 year old player yeah
so you know this whole thing with robert
wright going after business owners what
what are your thoughts on this with his
position on ceos having their salaries
increased by 1300 well i mean i think
you nailed it bitterness right
he sounds better towards them resentful
um you know the the first of all i'd be
interested in knowing when he's talking
about the pay increasing you know a lot
of this a lot of this is ceos oftentimes
have equity right and their value their
net worth goes up yeah um a lot more
than their pay this is one of the topics
we're getting into with elon musk a
little bit he was like you know people
are mad people are acting like i don't
pay enough in taxes because on this you
know i have hundreds of billions of
dollars and i'm not paying enough taxes
he's like my value is in my tesla stock
you know investors decided that tesla's
a trillion dollar company and i own 20
of that company which means i'm worth
200 billion dollars and that doesn't
mean i haven't realized those gains so
i'm not going to pay taxes on that on
that money and the second he starts
selling it off it goes down so it's not
even real yeah and it may go down the
value of tesla may may go way down next
year and then his net worth goes way
down but those things come and go but he
took the risk of building that company
almost went bankrupt at certain points
but yeah i mean ceos take a lot of risk
you know if they're providing value that
results in that kind of pay then that's
good for them and people should be
inspired to try to get to those roles
those positions rather than saying you
know what you make more than me that's
wrong we should make the same amount um
that kind of like
that's should make as much of the ceo
anybody like we work with hundreds and
hundreds of people i've never heard
anybody here in this building or any
other company i work for that say what
is the world you know what i should make
as much as pat you should hang out with
some more socialists
do you remember that company maybe in
like the corners of brooklyn but i don't
know anybody in the in the in the in the
real world that actually thinks that the
underwriter should make as much as the
ceo who was the guy that's never
happened it was the last time you were
in london who was the guy that uh that
was a ceo and he was making like a
couple million or five million a year
i had him on i had him as a kid yeah
yeah yeah he decided everybody
yeah right including himself right they
all got paid the same like does that
make him how did that work out for him
how did that work happened you know what
i asked him when i interviewed him what
i said let me ask a question you think
everybody should be paid the same i do
i said who owns your company he says i
do i said wow you're 100 i want 100
percent of company wow your company does
a lot so you're worth about 100 million
dollars
i am i said how many employees you got
you said 100 i said i think you should
follow your philosophy and give
everybody one percent of equity right
sure if you really share it or about and
you should have seen that if you've
never seen this interview you got to
watch that reaction he was so upset with
me when i asked that question i said
it's equity yeah you if you really want
to follow that philosophy follow it all
the way through right he says i'm going
to think about it
salary dude equity matters so much more
than that equity is the fastest way to
wealth creation in a business that's
growing you hold equity in that business
that's how you create wealth not by
trying to incrementally increase your
salary over and over and over again so
you know ceos that get there that figure
that out you know they deserve that
money yeah with millions of sleepless
nights missing a lot of parties by the
way that stant uh the whole uh 1322 i'm
gonna look it up because yesterday
ruslan sent me a text saying i don't
know if you saw that he sent a message
saying is this calculated based on this
i said just go read this link here's how
they came up with that with that formula
the formula that everybody keeps talking
about ceos were paid 350 times more than
employees all this other stuff go all
the way down what would you think was
the average ceo
of a top 350 firms in america in 1978
gerard what do you think is the average
salary
into the top three 50 firms in today's
equivalency or no no in that time um in
the not inflation just pure what was
their salary 1870 1978 what was their
salary well i mean you know what who
yeah
78 reggie jackson was the first million
dollar player right is that true so
let's say 500 000. okay cool go down by
the way this is the average of time less
than that right you're right it's less
than that now watch this
i looked at this i'm like there's no way
keep going keep going you'll see it it's
a very it's a uh chart right there the
average salary of a realized ceo
realized the compensation was 1.7
million dollars in 1978 what exactly
okay and today's 24 million dollars so
they're upset but they forget that in
1978 they were making 1.7 million tyler
what's up more than that tyler what's
1.7 million in 1978 dollars today
what's the equivalency
what's 1.7 million in 1978 these
conversations to me man are like they're
just so like distasteful but but here's
the part of gerard if it's not what
somebody else is making if it's not
unpacked it sounds like what up
are you hitting me of course these guys
shouldn't be paid this kind of money
this is what they do this is the
manipulation let's find out here go 1.78
million
you is that a million or billion i think
you put a billion good ones there which
is fine yeah
yeah so it's what three times more yeah
three times more than the average
inflation rate of 3.36 okay yeah so and
they've created more value bigger
companies more employees they get paid
more so the idea you build you win i
mean winners winners are supposed to win
i mean that's the idea man like so then
the formula is really they should say
it's increased three times more yeah
adjusted to inflation but they'll never
say that this is gonna lie with money so
just like the just like our great
emperor joe biden said the media needs
to do more to stop disinformation well
and this is this is what creates the
resentment that leads people to thinking
they're working in a toxic workplace
right like this is they don't have to
say they don't have to say everybody
should be paid the same they just have
to say they shouldn't be paid anywhere
near as much as they're being paid and
then they can get everybody else to
resent them that's right and then they
feel the pressure to have to readjust
how their company is structured to try
to make everybody happy
but seth they somehow make it like that
money should have been your money like
that money created was somehow supposed
to be somebody else's money everybody
looks at it like like it's a big slice
of pizza and if this guy has two slices
that's one less slice for you it's not
it's air in the balloon if anybody wants
to do a fun little thing draw a little
square in a balloon and blow air in it
and as the whole balloon gets bigger
watch that square get bigger too that
square's yours so when the economy grows
your square grows with it it's not
somebody else's great visual
what a great visual sauce talks money
visual by the way so we'll take care of
that okay so let me say one thing about
employment you're the last person and
we're changing let me just say one thing
about because obviously we've covered a
lot of what ceos thinks we have two i
assume you're ceo of your company or
founder ceo
a phrase that gets used or doesn't get
used enough i think uh is the great
reset everyone's talking about the great
resignation everyone's res uh resigning
resounding no these people are following
else i mean unless they're just sitting
home collecting unemployment which i
don't know how many people are still
continuing to do that if they are you
know loserville but i think a lot of
people really are just it's the great
reset basically what cova did
is a lot of people had to sit home for
whether it was three six nine 12 months
and say
is this really what i want to be doing
with my life is this am i working in
hospitality do i actually want to do
this or do i want to pursue something
else
so a lot of people have taken this time
to say
let me reassess really and you've
touched on this is this is this giving
me meaning and purpose in my life and a
lot of people have just changed
careers i think 50 percent of workers
are thinking about changing an actual
career so i know we're talking about a
lot of ceo and ceo pay and a great
resignation but these people need to
fall somewhere else there's always going
to be losers out there that have no
purpose or drive or willpower that want
to do something with their life and
they're just going to take the
government checks and the stimulus and
take the unemployment and just leech off
the government as much as they can but a
lot of people are saying you know what i
was working in hospitality
you know there's a difference you talk
about this all the time there's a
difference between having a job and
having a career so all this great
reshuffle if you know if
maybe that's a different term is people
saying you know what
i'm not finding fulfillment and finding
joy
let me find something i can do long term
that should be your goal i so what
percentage is that because the flip side
of that is the following which you have
to be very careful with so
this one guy post something the other
day freaking ridiculous thing he posted
the other day uh cindy kobo send it to
me i wish i want to give this guy a
shout out it was such a freaking
emotional thing to read
uh cindy you send it to me let me see
hang on one second guys i promise you
this story is worth you reading i'm
going to send this to you uh uh it's by
sean whalen i don't know if you follow
sean whelan or not yeah lion's not cheap
uh is that what it is i don't i actually
don't follow him that guy actually owes
me 10 000 cause we bet that
because we bet the guy with the beard
and the tattoos yeah yeah we bet much
like we saw bet who would win the
presidential elections
you got the money here yeah i did it you
paid me sean whalen's duck pull up pull
out what i just sent you and put it up
so this guy posts a story and i think it
has a lot to do with what you're saying
and people have to be very careful
because a lot of people can listen to
what you just said and said yeah that's
exactly what i'm doing
but the reality is you just could when
[ __ ] got tough let me show this to you
on what he put as a father with his son
so incredible incredible story uh so can
you make that bigger so that's him and
his son okay that picture itself is so
emotional when you just look at that kid
look at that kid right there all right
so i love being a dad more than i'll
ever be able to orate this is my son
after bloody war of a wrestling match
tonight real talk he's been hating
wrestling this year he's 15 and in his
head about a lot of stuff trying to
figure out a lot of things and he flat
out didn't want to wrestle i told him he
didn't have to wrestle but he had to get
a full-time job instead by a certain
date and he didn't so as a man of his
word he wrestled it's been a mental
battle for him i've been watching him
and working to be a supportive but
encouraging dad to hold space for him
but to push him this morning he got
pinned and i could feel his frustration
i could see in his energy he was mad and
dejected so after his match we had a
chat i told him as i've told him many
times that it's in a deep water a man is
forged in it's in the pain that the
strength is found and it's only the
hottest fires that makes the strongest
weapons
i told him earlier today that inside of
him was a savage a literal raging lunar
lunatic and that's who needed to show up
in the next match i told him to imagine
that this match determined if his family
literally lived or died i had him close
his eyes and visualized winning to
visualize his savage inside of him right
before he got on the mat tonight i
grabbed his face and told him i love you
now go be violent he went three rounds
bloodied his opponent and came off the
mat with the victory and blood pouring
out of his mouth i was emotional i was
choked up because i saw the savage i saw
the man who overcame the frustration and
fear and the man who will walk into life
and not suck him succumb to mediocrity
and pain life isn't is not fair life
isn't easy life wants to kill you
and beat you down at every turn and
tonight i saw my son dig into the place
in your soul that most humans run from
and avoid i saw in his eyes the savage
gladiator who will find peace in the
storm and who won't run from fear or
pain i love my children i love them
deeply when they are woven in my heart
they are woven in my heart and i ask god
every day to give me strength and
insight to lead them tonight was a
special experience i will never forget i
pray he never forgets this this is
emotional so to me adam as much as i
want to sit there and agree with you i
hate to say this to you a lot of people
come in when they're going through that
moat and you know what they're simply
doing things are hard and they're
quitting things if you quit because
things are hard and it's really you're
in the heat of the moment
you ain't making a career change you're
gonna go to another job or company and
shit's gonna get hard there as well and
then you're gonna quit again it's like
relationship marriage is hard
relationships the hardest thing you'll
ever do what are you gonna do go find
somebody else and it's going to get hard
again and hard again and hard again for
10 or 20 percent of people that make
sense that are going through that i
totally get it for the other 80 percent
that are selective hearing they're
looking for i saw a sign on a billboard
that told me change careers yeah we can
look for many reasons to get you know a
lot of different things that leave
behind people have to be very careful on
messaging again i may be wrong but i'm
telling you i saw something like this i
would much rather teach my kid to say
but we're good for him as a dad to say
you're gonna get a job you're gonna quit
wrestling you know you're going to do
one of those or keep doing wrestling
anyways maybe wrong it is what it is i
admire a man like this i just wanted to
give him props thank you for inspiring
me to share this story or else i would
have forgot let me just say my yeah i've
been at the same job for 15 years yeah
you know it's the finance industry you
know what happened in 2008. you think i
had a do you think it was interesting
but give that message bro no no what i'm
saying to you is inject that philosophy
that's fine dude you're a millionaire
because you didn't quit last 15 years i
agree yeah you're a freaking stab how
many freaking times could you been
distracted and done something i agree
however if i hated my job two years in
and i didn't want to stay there i would
have found something else
tell me you wake up every morning saying
i can't wait to do another live session
not even a little bit okay then right
exactly but how come you haven't quit
because now the more money's too good
but how many how many how many years
into it did you start making money
uh
a couple years in it took me a couple
years and then there was a dip after the
recession and then i had to build my way
back were in an industry that had a lot
of you know and a lot of people let me
just think to your appraisers here
everyone
in um
everyone was basically trying to get
into the mortgage industry in 2016 2007
2008 and then everyone in the mortgage
industry try to get into the financial
services industry and look at the tables
of turnout everyone is getting out of
the financial services industry trying
to get into the mortgage industry it's
just everyone wants to follow a hot
topic hot trend i get it but this goes
back to my initial point think yes
things will get tough you got to stick
it out it's not always fun it's always
sexy but you need to find a career and
ultimately what i'm saying is if you're
not happy in your job
and you just need to take that reset or
you know resignation whatever but find
your career
more power to you bro but yes like this
guy like the rest don't do it because
it's not going to be easy whatever i
think everybody knows
whatever career path you take it's going
to be [ __ ] tough
how long have you been doing the writing
business uh i've been at the helm of the
bee since 2018. okay but saying when did
you start your your writing career uh
well i've been an entrepreneur since
2012. okay so
at any point did you feel like quitting
or just not is this not for me
yeah i mean it's it's hard work you know
i don't i don't get to take days off you
know it's it it it bleeds into my
vacation time my family time you know
it's very difficult it's very it's
strenuous and there's also obviously you
know all the risk that comes along with
it you know not not every business
succeeds i've had my share of failures
investments that failed or startups that
failed
um so yeah it's hard you got it you got
to pick yourself back up and and
continue to just push forward and and
and believe in yourself that you can get
there if you continue to to to go
instead of quitting right um the minute
you resign yourself to just thinking i'm
going to take the easy road well you may
you may it may be easier sure but it's
certainly not going to be as lucrative
or as fulfilling in the end
because you didn't go out there and
accomplish as much i mean all these
things that you know the the the
challenge is the the
or what and the perseverance through it
is what builds character it's the same
thing like you never have an opportunity
to have any courage unless you're in
danger right like th these kinds of
things that the positives come in
response to the negatives um and and
that and that's how you that's how you
sharpen a blade is with that friction
right look at his eyes by the way look
at his eyes honestly look at his eye you
know for me i tell a story you know what
those guys tell you
you said you have an eight and a
six-year-old yeah yeah dude those eyes
are like
you think i want to be by the business
or my kids dog like what do you want me
to tell it's the pain of a person right
that that part needs to be given more so
if you enjoy this little short segment
from the podcast that we did here's
another short segment to watch or if you
want to see the entire podcast click
over here take care everybody bye-bye
[Music]